wendy williams wants to hit the airwaves
again with e.t learning new details
about how she's planning a tv comeback
we've got a lot to talk about here's
what we know
that's the tv personality in a rare
public outing following months of health
struggles limiting her mobility there's
wendy out and about with friends
wednesday night while dining in new york
city an eyewitness tells et wendy was
talking about getting back to work by
way of making a big comeback on tv
another priority for wendy accessing her
frozen accounts from wells fargo and
getting her money back
please let me have access to my money
this is not right
and again this is not fair as fans may
recall wendy is in an ongoing battle
with wells fargo and her former
financial advisor whom she claims is
keeping her from her millions and in
true wendy fashion she wanted to let her
supporters know what's really going on
laurie schiller and wells fargo
have
this
guardianship
petition
about
keeping me away from my money
this is not right
and you know this is not fair wells
fargo previously alleged the 57 year old
star is an incapacitated person who
needs a guardianship and can't access
her money but a resolution might be on
the horizon a source tells et her focus
at this time is regaining access to her
finances which she believes will happen
really soon and these details follow
major news for wendy's long time talk
show there's so many hot topics so
little time
last month it was announced the wendy
williams show is coming to an end at the
same time it was revealed sherry shepard
is set to get her own talk show titled
sherry i got some good news
the comedian has been one of many guest
hosts since last fall when wendy first
stepped away from the series amid
ongoing health issues
i'm very comfortable you know my
partners with the show everybody's ready
that's wendy speaking to good morning
america opening up in a pre-recorded
interview last month
health is very well and
i actually had a few appointments
you know i'm 57 now and i have the mind
and body of a 25 year old wendy claims
she's ready to get back to work and even
gives a specific time frame well give me
about three months i i there are private
things that i have to deal with and then
i'll be ready to come back
and be free and ready to do my thing
[Music]